that my brother was a good morning from
a few of the shows that Hank green and
the perfect strangers played together at
our last tour on the west coast I had
them enjoy today's video because one
we're going on to her again on the East
Coast and two because today I want to
talk about crowds every social animal
that seems gets a collective noun a
school of fish a gaggle of geese a pot
of whales a herd of cows and there are
lots of lesser-known and super-awesome
ones like a business of ferrets or a
murder of crows or a crash of rhinoceros
also a romp of otters that's really a
thing but humans since we mostly talk
about ourselves have given ourselves a
bunch of different collective nouns
depending on how large the group is and
what the group is doing and we're
working together it's a crew if you're
praying together it's a congregation if
you're fighting together it's an army if
you're mad and angry together that's a
mob but the most general term for a
group of humans I think is a crowd now
since the communication revolution of
the internet our society has become a
little bit obsessed with a new kind of
crowd I think it's a crowd tied together
not by being in the same place but by
common values or goals or interests the
Internet has enabled crowdfunding like
patreon an IndieGoGo and Kickstarter and
crowdsourcing which has built the Marvel
that is Wikipedia I mean at the wisdom
of the crowd and the crowd is up voting
things on Reddit and deciding whether or
not they want to watch youtube videos or
share things on Facebook and that's
helping all those different
organizations figure out how to curate
content more efficiently and effectively
we can now for the first time in human
history literally say that we are alone
in a crowd and I think that we are
forgetting that this crowd is made up of
individual people and I'm a little bit
uncomfortable with that but before I
talk about why that is I want to say
thank you to all of our patreon patrons
who have helped to fund scishow and
crash scores very effectively so far
we're almost 2/3 of the way to our pre
patreon switched funding levels so thank
you so much for doing that now when we
see it the crash course is raising over
$18,000 a month to fund educational free
video on the Internet
we have a hard time in our brains
thinking of that as being done by
individual people so we attribute it to
the crowd but it's not the crowd it's
not the culture it's individuals it's a
few people really less than a percent of
the total viewership of those shows who
have that magical combination of ability
and enthusiasm that makes
then interested in giving us money even
though they don't have to the way that I
understand the crowd and of course many
people would call like the audience of
this the 200,000 some people who are
gonna watch this video the crowd the way
that I understand it is heavily
influenced by actually going to places
and seeing real people which is why I
keep playing concerts up on a stage you
get a different in much more literal
view of what a crowd is it's a bunch of
people who have all individually come
together because they share a common
interest from the stage I can see the
crowd both as that marvelous human herd
all jumping in unison and also as a
bunch of individual people who's making
individual decisions so when I'm in the
audience I feel it very differently
whether I'm in the audience that's
participating in a crowdfunding campaign
or I'm watching music and I'm the one
jumping up and down in unison knowing
that my individual actions are valuable
but they're only really meaningful in
combination with a dozen or a hundred or
a thousand or a million other people I
love being my individual self but
there's also something really wonderful
about sacrificing that individuality for
a moment of giving or for a few hours of
enjoyment to the concert to a lot of
shows growing up a lot of shows that
grimy little venues with a bunch of
people that I didn't know and that I
would never know and those shows were
scary I found them scary pretty much
every single time I went to a show what
I learned there it wasn't that the crowd
was wise or powerful or effective which
is what we talk about now I think the
thing I learned was actually much more
important than that
I learned that crowds are kind or at
least they can be in the right situation
and I learned that if I let the barrier
of my individuality drop I wasn't afraid
of what I saw for a careful moment I
couldn't stop being me and I could just
be the crowd and I would gain a lot more
than I would lose John I'll see you on
Friday and nerdfighters in these areas I
will see you in April I hope can you
even imagine back in the past
thought that swans were caused by petit
god